everyone else on the plane is
unconscious you are the only one who can
land it and you've never flown a planate
before what do you do next I'm at
virtual aviations million pound
simulator in Cambridge with Morag and
Matt and my job is simple land the plane
and show you how to do it too you know
just in case and don't forget this is
part of comic relief School of YouTube
everyone here has given their time for
free to make this happen and we hope you
learn something from it but remember
we're doing this to raise money for
children worldwide who have limited or
no access to education at all details of
how you can help are on screen now and
if you can donate please do all right
let's land this thing Tom then on his
approach into London heo Airport very
strong Crosswinds to contend with whoa
who so wrestling a bit with a control
column bringing it back to Center only
stops the rooll continuing he needs to
nudge it the other way to get on course
time wait time wait time trust back
swaying in in the wind and he reduces
the thrust to get the nose done got I
think it's too much he's coming in too
low pull up I'm trying there's the
warning system ordering him to pull up
and he has got the nose back but is it
enough is he going to land short of that
Runway he's almost done he is short and
veering
left that's technically on the runway
not on the runway there lucky there's no
buildings there but he's got a problem
he doesn't realize it I don't
think why why are we not stopping here
but he has accidentally disabled the
auto break so he's not going to
[Music]
stop not a bad effort from Tom Morag
next can she do better a set of Lights
next to the runway guide her on height
if they appear white she knows she's too
high red for too low but she's
struggling here with the
Crosswinds just needs to keep calm and
nudge the 737 back on course which she
has done nicely and she'll be guided by
those dials on height and Direction sink
rate she is correcting pull up
correcting too much she needs to pull up
again and now she's overdone that too so
she's very high now with a Runway ahead
there it is she's supposed to be down on
that Runway so she's in trouble here
this plane is getting away for her at
the moment automatic emergency
instructions getting a bit frantic with
we are on our way down and there's only
one way this flight will finish and it's
not good finally it's Matt at the
controls and looking good in these early
stages the flight director instrument
showing him he is almost bang on The
Descent
path and he needs to follow the small
purple diamonds with the control column
and that will keep him on
course and he is very much on course of
the minute using the thrust lever
skillfully there to adjust his height
he's keeping calm just small inputs on
the controls keeping him pretty much
online and he's heading straight for
that Runway he seems pleased at that
this is a really good approach easy does
it now is he going to miss the runway
surely not tilting left a bit and that
was probably the wing clipping the
runway but he is done and now on the
rudder pedals to steer it back towards
the runway and that that was a very good
effort so at the end of the round and
the end of the contest Matt is the clear
winner I think I did that good J you did
the you're the only one to make
touchdown on the
runway if you're ever the only one who
can land a plane that is how you do it
and if you learn something then please
help someone who hasn't got that chance
£5 could help a Zambian orphan go to
school for a month and get a meal every
day there perhaps the only meal that
they'll get so please pick up the phone
click the link on screen and donate if
you can thank you to Virtual Aviation
thank you to Gordon Burns for the
wonderful voice over and thank you to
comic relief for setting all this up
that is how you land a plate in an
emergency